I am Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report hey let's say the guy down the
block from where you live is
counterfeiting money and he's buying
stuff he he created an extension on his
house he bought a new boat he bought a
new car he bought five new cars he
bought another new boat he bought a lot
of jewelry he's living large would you
say that the wealth on that street is
disproportionately heading into that
guy's house because he's able to
counterfeit money and spend that money
would you say that I mean that's not
hard to comprehend right Stacy yeah
we're gonna talk about Cantillon effect
and how that spreads down through a
systemic form of discrimination and a
systemic inequality because this is an
issue obviously that is spread around
the world you know with these uprisings
about the George Floyd murder which is
spread around the world and I think the
underlying issue here is the monetary
system around the world that's the base
of why everybody around the world is
protest and why this has spread around
the world and it goes to this little
clip from the Federal Reserve Chairman
Jay Powell Marty bent posted this and he
said deflecting blame never a good sign
individuals are waking up to the biggest
scam to sweep earth over the last
century the Federal Reserve fixed the
money fix the world equality is
something that's been with us
increasingly for more than four decades
and it's it's not really related to
monetary policies or before it's more
related to there are a lot of theories
on what caused that but it's been
something that's more or less been going
up consistently for more than four
decades and there are lot of different
theories right well let's keep in mind
that Jerome Powell is a big shareholder
in stocks and he's the guy who gave
black sock the job of buying stocks for
his bank the central bank and he gave
him the money to do so so he prints a
lot of money he gives it to Blackrock
and then they buy stock in these ETFs
that he owns Jay Powell and the stock
prices go up and he makes money with the
money that he printed
that's interesting so is the end of
better than the guy at the end of the
block who's counterfeiting money in
their basement and then buying lots of
gold jewelry and cars and boats and then
say wow that guy's got a lot of wealth
yeah he's suspending the money he just
printed is it any different no it's not
any different
not at all different now let's follow up
on that that story that you've created
of a neighborhood where one guy gets to
print all this money and he buys up all
the wealth producing assets of the town
the steel production company the steel
manufacturer he buys the auto
manufacturer and he buys the actual
underlying land to most of the property
so has to you know everybody has to pay
him rent and then people realized and he
gets found guilty of like counterfeiting
but he just has to stop doing it okay
like but he still gets to own the wealth
his family gets to inherit the wealth
and they get to go forward obviously
they're going to be dissin else in the
entire economy is disadvantage against
this guy because he inherited all this
ill-gotten wealth so that is part of the
system that we have the problem in
America right now with you know the the
disadvantage that black Americans have
because of the history of slavery that
they went into Jim Crow which took
wealth from African American black
Americans and so they came at the game
they started it you know from 1964 with
the Civil Rights Act they started into
this hyper globalized American Empire at
a huge disadvantage compared to the
average white person but then from 1971
whoever had the assets got in first on
the pyramid scheme and so we're gonna go
into some of the charts on that so the
way that this was played out in the
black community and we saw that during
the Katrina disaster quite brilliantly
laid out before our eyes in that area
around New Orleans there's a lot of
black homes owners ship of homes the
Katrina disaster allowed predatory banks
to swoop in steal their homes from them
based on the fraudulent loans that were
made by the banks and who owns most of
those properties people like Warren
Buffett at Berkshire Hathaway so here he
had a disenfranchisement it's one of the
biggest disenfranchised with other black
community in America sense live days and
how do they do it they used interest
rate apartheid they use money printing
money counterfeiting jpowel
whoever was at the helm of the Fed at
that time could have been warned could
have been whoever was I mean they were
involved in this wholesale
disenfranchisement of the scoop and this
he can make a fifty examples of exactly
the same game play from the same book
yeah the game started the pyramid scheme
started the the Ponzi scheme started in
1971 when Nixon closed the gold window
so it's what advantage how many hotels
on the Monopoly game board did you own
when the game started and I saw
brilliant viral video where this woman
was explaining like you know black
Americans had to work for 400 times
around the board the Monopoly board
building houses and buying properties
for the white people playing the game
and then suddenly they're sold okay now
play the game and that were 400 times
they're on the board collecting
properties now you start to join the
game but on top of that we have a
systemic thing where anybody so there
are a whole bunch of losers systemically
the the Cantillon effect you know Jay
Powell is in charge of printing money he
gets to print money he presses a button
he said this on 60 minutes he prints
money as much as he wants it can only go
to those broker dealers first it goes
through certain bankers first and those
bankers decide who to lend it to you
know we're gonna let I'm gonna skip
forward to one with Jamie Dimon Jamie
Dimon we all saw him take the knee in
front of a Chase Manhattan Bank right
but so he gets to decide who gets the
wealth who gets the free money that
they've given and they're charging
interest on that free money that Jay
Powell has just given him Jamie Dimon
takes a knee but won't lend to black
Americans in DC this is a headline from
CBS News in 2018 and they pointed out
that JPMorgan Chase rarely lends to
minorities in one major US city
Washington DC the heart of power in
America over 40% of the population is
black American just 2% of JPMorgan
Chase's loans
Washington DC just 2% that's 23 of the
1119 loans made in 2018 went to blacks
in Washington DC it's just as few went
to Latinos there this is the same sort
of situation it's like those loans in
our Fiat system of a post gold standard
dollar whoever has the most debt gets to
build the wealth with this counterfeit
money and own all the assets great Jamie
Dimon is part of the financial apartheid
in America there is apartheid in America
it's done with interest rates and loans
and the banking cartel and to kind of
expand on this black monopoly idea how
come when blacks roll the dice on
monopoly it always lands on you got to
go to jail you know there's that jail
yeah you know on the Monopoly board you
go to jail right so now blacks are
playing Monopoly in America oh you got
to go to jail again oh you got to go to
jail again Oh cuz jail is now a property
development scheme by the likes of
Berkshire Hathaway Warren Buffett where
it's not for some kind of rehabilitation
or some kind of part of the judicial
system
it's a monopoly called the prison
industrial complex where blacks are now
working for a 50 cents a day and in fact
overturned the amendment that outlaw
slavery it's alive and well in America's
jails Thank You black monopoly Warren
Buffett and Jamie Dimon again let's look
at the big macro picture and how this
happens and how a Cantillon effect
creates the inequality that j-pal at the
top of the show we showed that he says
this doesn't happen so correlation
doesn't necessarily equal causation but
this is pretty you know strong
indictment I think so here's a chart
that went around this past week looking
at the biggest theft in history growth
and productivity and hourly compensation
since 1948 you see compensation started
stopped growing in 1971 productivity
continued to increase so that is a form
of theft again 1971 if you weren't on
the playing board if you weren't on the
Monopoly board in 1971 working to get
ahead then became harder as you see from
that productivity data the more you work
the more wealth you created for the top
the capital owners the asset owners
the more you worked the less you were
paid commensurately so you had to have
been working before 1971 you had to have
been you know in a cushy job and built
your assets by then and we see that
playing out with the that data looking
at black versus white America in terms
of their wealth not their income their
wealth the intergenerational wealth the
black/white economic divide isn't just
big it's as bad or worse than it was
before 1968 let that sink in black
wealth today remains less than 10% that
of whites just like in the late 1960s
white wealth surges black wealth
stagnates this is since 1960s and you
say black wealth has stayed the same
because the rules the game once they got
on the playing board after the Civil
Rights Act of 1964 well the rules of the
game changed with a Fiat standard the
cap chilling effect that Jay Powell
presides over right it's a soft genocide
of blacks in America and since 1971 the
white community has been trying to tell
the black community that wages don't
matter because they've been saying like
what wages don't matter your because of
efficiencies of productivity gains your
car goes faster so wages don't matter
because of productivity gains and
efficiency your computers and electronic
equipment that's made in China now for
the job they used to have you know it
works better it works faster the screens
are bigger and it's faster that's why
you don't need wages wages are bad
savings are bad the paradox of thrift
the savings glut having our individual
sovereign sees evil right so that's the
propaganda and who comes the propaganda
man is the it's the Federal Reserve the
Chairman they say it wages that's that's
for chumps what you want you want you
want counterfeit coupons from from the
central bank that's what you want
and of course nobody gets in the way and
corrects them because all the media then
would stand up and stay like you know
what this is wrong have all been bought
out by the same corporations but
everybody's noticing we see that in the
Bitcoin community especially you will
see that in the second half that people
realize that it's a rigged game and yes
black and
Americans came on to the playing board
that is monopoly this pyramid scheme
Fiat pyramid scheme yes they came in
later than the majority of white people
but the fact is it does discriminate
against all it is an economic paradigm
that is rigged against the vast majority
of people including entrepreneurs
including people who are not like close
to the money printer that's why you're
seeing protests around the world that's
why you're seeing central banks being
burned down in Lebanon there's the same
underlying thing it doesn't matter I
mean you know this has been this was an
issue in the 60s people leaders of the
civil rights movement talked about this
economic the system as corrupt and this
was while that we were still on the gold
standard so it maybe wasn't as benignly
corrupt as now right it is a global
phenomenon because all the central banks
are doing now on a coordinated basis the
same thing to move trillions from the
many to the few and so you have the
global insurrection against banker
occupation that we've talked about
before all these groups like black lives
matter Occupy Wall Street Arab Spring
uprisings in Greece all over the Europe
all over Asia all over the world they
all have one common theme its interest
rate apartheid financial counterfeiting
by a few to disenfranchise the many and
that's why gold is going up and when you
see the stock market going up it's not
because these companies are making more
money is because the underlying currency
that they're priced in the u.s. dollar
is collapsing because now what's the
endgame as as anyone who with the two
eyes can can tell you and as we go I'd
like to say look up gild noble he was a
very famous black journalist from the
60s and 70s that's what we need today
somebody to tell it like it is I'm gonna
take a break when we come back much more
coming your way
[Music]
welcome back to the Kaiser report I'm
Max Keiser time now to go to Eric Latham
you can find him on Twitter and I am the
character Eric welcome to the Kaiser
report welcome guys thank you for having
me
now you have gone viral on Bitcoin
Twitter for a speech you gave at black
lives matter in Los Angeles what did you
say I told the people that it's time for
us to opt out and exit the economy and
the way we do that is by using Bitcoin I
also introduced my three-point plan
moving forward and the three-point plan
includes Bitcoin volunteering and voting
I feel that these three macro ideas can
encompass a lot of non micro ideas and
moving the movement forward the black
lives matter movement oh you know this
is the latest chapter in the civil
rights movement in America and the fight
for freedom and emancipation and
equality for other black community in
America going back hundreds of years and
I think we're at an inflection point
where the black community has realized
that as long as you're operating in the
fiat money system there will be no
justice and so bitcoin is the first time
in history where money and State have
been separated and you can become
individually sovereign which is a very
empowering message am i right Eric
correct yeah I mean it's Martin Luther
King and not the max and all other black
activists were aware or if they had
Bitcoin they'd been all over it I mean
it's the only solution
uhm as Audrey Lorde says you can't she
said something to the effect that you
can't dismantle the Masters house with
the Masters tools or she said something
to that effect and so we can't use the
financial system that has actually
enslaved us an oppressor to rid
ourselves of oppression and you know
finance and enslavement that one so we
have this new tool and you know the
boycott is a cornerstone of the of the
you know black protest movement and
Bitcoin is the nuclear
of boycotts so let's put let's put that
in our toolkit let's volunteer and build
our communities and also let's not
forget the ballot box and when I'm
actually voting also mention you know
let's let's get out there on the
community level our neighborhood in City
Council's you know let's put all these
tools together and let's rebuild this
time that it's time to exit this [ __ ]
and you know let's rebuild all all is
included but especially you know the
black community who is just under a
tremendous amount of oppression in this
country beating you know it's time for
something something build with the
strategies we have today it's the
ultimate form of passive resistance you
know I remember back in 2008 during the
financial crisis the the the subprime
crisis once again the black community
was just absolutely decimated by evil
bankers you know that has to take
basically stolen so many houses in the
black community around Louisiana New
Orleans in those areas after many
decades of building up a strong
community suddenly within a few months
it's all gone because of the bailouts
for the bankers who made fraudulent
loans however the homeowners who had
built up a community they were not
offered any assistance in fact they were
the victim of these fraudulent bankers
including the big names like Wells Fargo
one of Warren Buffett's big stocks that
was involved in this wholesale
disenfranchisement of a whole community
so getting back to Bitcoin Eric it's
uncomplicated bull which is great right
because so many times when the black
community achieves some level of
financial independence you know North
Carolina there was black Wall Street at
one point there have been really great
thriving black communities America for
years and then somehow they magically
get ransacked disappeared memory hall
destroyed but bitcoin is uncomfortable
Eric yes so I mean it's just the same
story even with a reach instruction
there was this black Bank there was this
Bank and uh the black community wasn't a
black man gonna believe but it was a
fate that the black community we're
leaving all their funds in and you know
the story low and behold that Bank is
looted you know they are the wealth of
the community gets looted and it's the
same story over and over
you know somehow we get taken advantage
of because we don't have the keys to the
printing press or we don't have the keys
to the paintball or some guy gets off
free and clear with the money that we're
storing somewhere else and that day is
over it's a beautiful day that day is
over we have a life raft to get on and
to get off the sinking ship of the
Titanic that were trying to call society
at this moment and it's time to rebuild
and with these tools
it is uncompensated it is ours and it is
a sense of Stokes of ownership and you
know that's that's pretty much the only
way I can see forward so as as long as
this idea catches on as long as this
idea keeps getting promoted I think it's
just gonna be a no-brainer in the black
community I said this is the financial
system we need to be you take it back to
1968 of course I was old I was around I
was watching the Olympics and we had
that seminal moment Tommie Smith and
John Carlos Carlos holding you know
presenting the black salute with black
gloves on on the podium the winning
podium they won their races and this
became an iconic image for the black
community going forward and as far as
images go today in the 21st century in
2020 it's not so much those photos that
capture iconic moments but it's about
memes it's about Twitter it's about
social media so how are you finding life
on social media since this video dropped
of you at the black lives matter moment
preaching the merits of Bitcoin you know
if it has gone viral and has blown up
what's what's been going on in the last
week or so in your life Eric not much
um people are just really appreciative
I'm really appreciative about um I feel
like it gave it gave some win to the
Bitcoin community it let us it was a
reminder of why we're all here what
we're all doing and why we're putting so
much time into this project I also
wanted people to but I don't want the
message to get lost though I don't want
people to focus on me I want people to
start figuring out how they can
volunteer and spread this word some
spread the Bitcoin
work some more like you know let's be
Bitcoin ambassadors let's let's get out
in our community and keep spreading this
word let's keep this word buzzing so
it's been it's been really encouraging
it's a great community to be a part of
and I actually had a meeting at the last
lightning high Hawk spirit I jumped in
on one of route Souls one of the guy who
created the arrestee blitz a Bitcoin and
lightning note and we were building on
some ideas on how we can keep this idea
going so it's a great community of
volunteers I think it was reinforcing to
the community why we're here and
everyone really appreciated that message
so I'm really thankful for that so my
knowledge and I've been in this
community since 2011
I don't really run into any racial
conflict at all wherever I go around the
world there's a there's a Bitcoin nation
and it's a multicolored multi-ethnic
multifaceted multi country it's just
there's everyone just focused on this
hard money uncomplicated ball really
separation of state and money and
ethnicity and color never comes into it
but I do also live in the United States
of America and I agree with those who
have who say that the foundation of the
American political system is white
supremacy so it doesn't really it
doesn't matter how open you are and how
much love you have in your heart if you
live in a nation whose premises white
supremacy that's a it's gonna be tough
to overcome in my opinion Eric what are
your thoughts so that's the status flow
and how does the status flow stay in
place with the financial system that
supports it so as long as we have this
financial system that's ran by the Fed
or you know couple mysterious guys in
the room we don't get to see then we'll
keep the status flow of white supremacy
in place and that's another reason why I
promote Bitcoin to the black community
because this is our tool to upend the
status quo that's been oppressing us and
literally has had its knee in our neck I
feel like if you have been as the status
quo you look in the level the levers of
power that keep that status quo in place
and therefore you can up in what supreme
theoretically as I've been saying since
2011 because I've been following this
debate for quite some time in the debate
about reparations and there's a lot of
logic to it and there's a lot to be said
for it when I said in 2011 is and this
is also quoted in Isaiah Jackson's book
Bitcoin of black America that the black
community and this was a Bitcoin was a
dollar if it accumulated enough Bitcoin
at a dollar it wouldn't have to really
worry about reparations because they
would the black community would have all
the wealth and the fiat money world
would be collapsing the case of
reparations and that model has been done
before we know that the Japanese
received an apology and reparations for
their experiences when they were thrown
in internment camps but at the same time
you know it's I think we're so fed up
that we're over it it's just like keep
your money but we don't even want to
deal with you anymore we're done
releasing you know this is their thing
we're out and we have this new economy
we can build so you know maybe when
we're further along they'll try to lure
us back and say oh we had the same story
but you know I just I just feel like
we're so fed up we're over it we just
don't even talk to us anymore we're done
you know yeah Bitcoin you buy in the
black community when when this message
goes out what are some of the pushback
that you get if any what is you know
this is a Bitcoin for got a learning
curve I mean it's not the easiest thing
in the world to wrap your mind around it
takes folks you know you got to dig into
it for a while what are you finding out
there what are some of the the
objections or questions people have
right off the top like if you had a
group of folks in a room right now how
would you explain it coming up with this
analogy so my analogy is let's say the
financial system is public
transportation so the financial system
is a city bus it sucks there's no air it
never runs on time and now you have this
new system that's similar to lyft or
uber where all you need is your phone
and it's accessible it comes to wherever
you go wherever you are and it takes you
to wherever you need to go and I think
people can understand that parallel so
where you have a government system that
slow and sluggish and then you have this
alternative solution that's quick and
nimble so but you're right it's so new
that's been I think who we who are in
the space we forget just how new and
innovated it is that when you introduce
it to people they're like
but oh no that could never happen and
it's like no it is happening so that's
why when I present it to people I'm
telling people the revolution is already
started you know don't be late on it you
know let's let's let's contribute but um
it is there you know when I introduced
it to crowds I noticed there's this
weird like ambient like silence because
like voting and voluntary makes so much
sense and then when I heard you do spit
coin they're hearing it and it seems
like they're hearing it for the first
time in other words whether there's a
need you don't really need to spend a
lot of time explaining it for people in
Argentina for people in Venezuela for
people in countries around the world
that are suffering from hyperinflation
they jump on Bitcoin right away because
it fits a need and they get into it
immediately and this fits a need in
black America certainly for individual
sovereignty dignity justice and we got
to go Eric Latham thanks so much for
being on the cosna report keep it up
well that's gonna do it for this edition
of the Kaiser report with me max Kaiser
and Stacy Herbert like to thank our
guest he's known as I am the character
on Twitter the one and only
Eric Latham you can catch us on Twitter
at Kaiser report until next time bye
y'all
[Music]